vamos a resolver otro problema que mandó
un usuario de khan academy cuyo nombre
es corta yo o contagio o algo así espero
que se pronuncie pero es importante es
que es un problema muy interesante y de
las cosas interesantes que tiene ese
problema es que no involucra matemáticas
muy rimbombantes e involucran una forma
elegante de aplicar sencillas
matemáticas pero bueno mucha plática y
mejor intentemos resolver este problema
que por cierto también no sabía dónde
ponerlo si la sección de álgebra o en la
sección de acertijos mentales y dice un
policía a caballo empieza su recorrido
al final de una fila de soldados que
marchan y llega hasta el frente de la
fila después gira en sentido contrario y
regresa hasta el final de la fila si el
policía tiene una velocidad del triple
que la velocidad que tiene la fila de
soldados y esta fila tiene un largo de
100 metros ok ya son muchos datos así
que primero déjenme dibujar esta fila de
100 metros y la voy a poner un poco
gruesa
aquí tenemos nuestra fila de soldados de
100 metros y déjeme esperar
perdón es exitoso directamente el
micrófono te voy a dejar sordo pero
bueno aquí tenemos a esta fila de
soldados que por cierto nosotros sabemos
que mide 100 metros esta fila entonces
aquí tenemos 100 metros y todos estos
soldados va trotando quién sabe qué
hacen pero van a una cierta velocidad
entonces están moviendo hacia la derecha
a una cierta velocidad y bueno también
dice que tenemos un oficial lo que era
una por aquí debe estar porque debe
estar aquí un policía perdón
espero no estarle cambiando el título al
policía un policía que va a caballo el
cual empieza su recorrido hasta el final
de esta fila de soldados entonces aquí
tengo a mi caballo esta es mi
representación del policía a caballo y
este policía se va a mover hasta llegar
al frente de esta fila de soldados y
después se va a dar la media vuelta y se
va a regresar hasta donde empezó su
recorrido al final de la fila de
soldados y bueno lo importante que
quiero que veas es lo siguiente que aquí
dicen que el policía tiene una
del triple que la velocidad que tiene la
fila de soldados esto es muy importante
porque si los soldados van a una
velocidad deben entonces el policía va a
una velocidad de 3 ve va al triple de
velocidad de la que van los soldados y
bueno vamos a pensar ahorita en dos
primeros tiempos voy a decir que te uno
es el tiempo en el que el policía llega
hasta el frente de la fila de soldados y
bueno te dos va a ser el tiempo en el
que el policía regresa es decir el
tiempo que le toma al policía llegar de
nuevo al final de la fila de soldados
muy bien ahora pensemos qué es lo que va
a pasar después de que transcurra el
tiempo de uno bueno si nosotros pensamos
en la fila de soldados los soldados van
a moverse una cierta distancia qué
distancia se van a mover bueno
recordemos la fórmula que la distancia
es igual a la velocidad por el tiempo a
la rapidez por el tiempo y entonces
estos soldados se van a mover una
distancia que va a ser igual a la
velocidad que tienen que sven por el
tiempo pero estamos hablando del tiempo
uno por lo tanto lo que van a moverse
los soldados
por el tiempo 1 y si ahora pensamos en
el policía caballo pues se va a mover
exactamente lo mismo pero además los va
a alcanzar y por lo tanto lo que va a
pasar con el policía caballo es que a
esta distancia que se van a mover la
fila de soldados le vamos a tener que
aumentar la fila misma de soldados
porque porque el caballo lo que va a
hacer es moverse toda la fila de
soldados hasta llegar al frente de la
fila de soldados justo así habíamos
definido a tf1 por lo tanto si los
soldados se mueven una distancia de
deporte 1 a esto hay que aumentarle 100
que son los 100 metros que tiene la fila
de soldados y bueno es lo que se va a
mover el policía caballo si nosotros
seguimos la lógica pero si nosotros
utilizamos la fórmula pues esto va a ser
igual a 3 por deporte 1 utilizando la
fórmula de la distancia distancias
igualdad la rapidez por el tiempo es
decir para una rapidez a una velocidad
de 3 b por el tiempo 1 y bueno si te das
cuenta aquí tenemos a b por t 1 de aquí
a 3 por deporte 1 por lo tanto lo
podemos reducir un poco me va a quedar
que 100 es igual a 3 deporte 1 - deporte
1 es lo mismo que 2
por deporte 1 o de otra manera he vivido
todo entre dos me queda que 50 es igual
a la velocidad por el tiempo 1 o
podremos pensar inclusive que es justo
lo que estamos viendo la fila de
soldados muy bien pero aquí tenemos una
ecuación con dos incógnitas 50 es igual
a la velocidad por el tiempo 1 esto es
lo que logramos cuando nosotros pensamos
en qué es lo que pasa con el policía
caballo cuando va hacia la derecha ahora
vamos a pensar qué es lo que pasa con el
caballo cuando regresa entonces el
policía a caballo llega hasta el frente
de la fila de soldados y ahora tenemos
aquí al policía a caballo y lo que va a
hacer es regresar hasta llegar al final
otra vez de la fila de soldados entonces
ahora se va a regresar y tiene una
velocidad de 320 pero yo lo que quiero
que analices es que si nosotros nos
paramos aquí y vamos a una velocidad de
3 b y después la fila está justo aquí y
va a una velocidad de hasta la derecha
entonces el policía caballo se está
acercando al final de la fila de
soldados con una velocidad de 4 v porque
el policía va a una velocidad de 320 y
por su parte la fila
a una velocidad de pero acercándose al
policía fíjate bien si yo tuviera aquí
un móvil que se está acercando a una
velocidad de 60 kilómetros por hora y yo
me estoy acercando a su vez a ese móvil
a una velocidad de 60 kilómetros por
hora
realmente si paramos al móvil y lo vemos
fijamente lo vemos de una manera
estática
yo me estaría cercano al móvil a una
velocidad de 120 kilómetros por hora es
justo lo que está pasando aquí por lo
tanto el jinete se está acercando al
final de la fila de soldados a una
velocidad de 4 veces la velocidad a la
que se va moviendo en la fila de
soldados y por lo tanto me va a quedar
que 4 veces la velocidad por el tiempo 2
ojo
recuerda que ya no estamos hablando del
tiempo 1 estamos hablando del tiempo 2
el tiempo que nos toma regresar al final
de la fila de soldados esto tiene que
ser igual a 100 metros que es justo lo
que mide la fila de soldados y ahora sí
de aquí paso dividiendo este 4 me queda
que la velocidad por el tiempo 2 es
igual a 25 y ya tengo una segunda
ecuación pero ahora tengo dos ecuaciones
con tres incógnitas vamos a fijarnos
bien qué me dice el problema
para ver qué es lo que quiere dice qué
distancia recorre la fila de soldados en
el tiempo en el que el policía caballo
regresa al final de la fila qué
distancia recuerde la fila de soldados
en el tiempo en el que el policía
caballo regresa al final de la fila es
decir que realmente lo que queremos es
cuánto se mueve este punto relativo al
tiempo en el que el policía caballo va y
viene es decirte uno más de dos lo que
yo quiero saber es cuánto se mueve la
fila de soldados y por lo tanto recuerda
que la distancia es lo mismo que la
velocidad por el tiempo y entonces lo
que queremos es la distancia que se
mueve esta fila de soldados que es igual
a la velocidad que tiene la fila de
soldados que por cierto siempre es ven
por el tiempo pero el tiempo total del
recorrido es decirte uno más de dos el
tiempo que se tardó el policía a llegar
hasta el frente y el tiempo que se tarda
el policía en regresar hasta el final de
la fila y entonces me va a quedar que la
distancia va a ser igual y ahora vamos a
distribuir esta vez multiplicando a t1 y
la t2 entonces me quedan que la
distancia es igual a
velocidad por el tiempo 1 más la
velocidad por el tiempo 2 pero estos dos
resultados ya lo sé la velocidad por el
tiempo 1 es igual a 50 que es lo que se
mueve la fila de soldados en el tiempo
en que el policía a caballo llega hasta
el frente por lo tanto ya puedes
sustituir esto y aquí tengo que ver por
t 2 es igual a 25 por lo tanto ahora sí
si ponemos este valor justo aquí me va a
quedar que la distancia es igual a 50
más
este valor lo podemos sustituir por esta
igualdad que tenemos aquí la velocidad
por el tiempo 2 es igual a 25 entonces
poniendo el 25 justo aquí me va a quedar
que la distancia total que recorrió la
fila de soldados durante todo este
tiempo fue de 75 metros y aquí esta
parte de lo bonito de todo esto porque
date cuenta que no necesitamos
explícitamente el valor de ven ni el
valor de tf1 ni el valor de 2 justo aquí
está el meollo del asunto porque nunca
nos dicen cuál es la velocidad de la
fila de soldados sólo nos dicen que el
policía va al triple de esa velocidad de
cualquier manera espero que hayan
disfrutado del problema y si es así
pueden agradecerle a korta yo
por este problema